hey guys and welcome back to steampunks
to show where we go through all of the
games that have come out over the last
week on Steam and let you know what's
worth playing my name is Jess and I'm ed
and without further ado let's talk about
what's worth talking about what's your
first game all right well I played this
game called dead in Finland which I
initially thought was gonna be a banner
saga in darkest dungeon mashup turns out
that's kind of the case but not really
this is more of a really really deep D&D
cool it's set in a Viking universe and
your house is pillaged and you have to
escape by a stolen boat with your wife
and angsty daughter and your crazy
sister-in-law who's a witch of some kind
and you end up stranded in this island
with a handy campsite and your goal is
to survive it's a survival game first
and foremost you'll need to keep an eye
on things like food and water as well as
fire along with resources like wood
stone to build things for your campsite
as well as just maintain your settlement
and your characters so there's a few
different sort of layers to this game
the survival lairs sort of a turn-based
system where there are three phases
throughout the tie game so this morning
afternoon night so with your morning and
afternoon you can actually sort of do
things like perform tasks like exploring
or like scavenging an area or gathering
wood and the evening phases a table
reserved for I'm sort of chatting with
your surviving members as well as
dishing out of food and water rations to
keep them hydrated and fed so you need
to explore the island as well as
maintain your campsite so this island is
huge and exploring will reveal sort of
little bits of the world map one tiny
square at a time and each square will
have something you can usually take
action on so like a treat and gather
it's a special SAP from or stuff you can
search for resources and they'll usually
be a choice to make so you can either do
one or the other you search one place or
a different place and you might get
varying results depending on it certain
people are obviously good at certain
things yeah and there are skill checks
which relate to scavenging harvesting
every character has a bunch of skills
like physical mental skills
concentration endurance and all of those
break down to even more niche sub skills
to denote how good they are and
everything from like fishing to
gardening to just like stealth and stuff
every character also has a well being a
sort of stat sheet so you have to manage
fatigue hunger sickness injury and
depression most of the decisions you
make
relationship to other characters but
also between other characters themselves
and the third layer is on the battle
system which definitely has some serious
darkest dungeon vibes in that you're
positioning on the battlefield matters
the presentation is very influenced by
darkest dungeon the one sort of
different thing is that there are
ability points so you can kind of
perform multiple skills during your
turns in battle the characters in battle
look really cold I'm not really a fan of
the art in conversation I just think
they look a bit you know wonky and the
writings a bit iffy - I don't think it
can decide whether it wants to be modern
or Nordic there's a bit of both so it's
20 bucks on Steam and this would be a
pretty sweet portable game if you've got
a laptop or surface or something to play
on
yeah that's dead in Finland it's a
pretty deep D&D experience we must
survive
alright well speaking of deep
experiences particularly in RPGs I
played a game this week called tower in
time
it's very Divinity baldur's gate esque
isometric on G it's party based as well
and the thing that does separate this
from those games is that it is purely a
dungeon crawler so in that way it's kind
of like torchlight you're sort of just
going through the levels of a dungeon
but there are a ton of quests to do and
there's a really solid story the game
takes place in a fantasy realm called
Ostara
something massive has happened that has
pretty much decimated the land but what
there is in the middle of that
cataclysmic landscape is this tower has
appeared one of the things that's really
interesting is the characters themselves
don't really know what happened in their
history that's kind of the point of the
Cataclysm it's just like messed up
everything and now no one knows what
happened or why so you pick up books as
you go that are basically cutscenes that
play out and give you little clues to
where the story has come from there's
really great voice acting in these
scenes which is awesome and I really
love the choice of their graphics the
layouts in the dungeon are really lovely
to explore and even though there is no
dialogue the music is really excellent
it's very um Heroes of Might and Magic
so the way combat works in this game is
pretty interesting
so you'll approach someone who's kind of
rappers
of the combat much like you would in
heroes actually and then decide whether
or not you actually want to engage in
that combat if it's an ambush you don't
have a choice once you're in the fight
you can slow down time as much as you
want so while it's not turn-based there
is certainly that urban flow that you
get into while using abilities waiting
for cooldowns you can have your
characters stand their guard so they
only move when you tell them to move or
they can attack automatically characters
don't get experience for beating up
enemies in this game instead the way
that you level your characters is by
paying for levels when you go back to
town the town really functions as kind
of a place for you to level your
characters to craft items crop better
weapons you can enhance skills or pick
new ones and new levels grant new skills
and on top of that there's also
alignment which shows how the party
members feel about each other in this
game it affects morale and it affects
when you are in battle so you get buffs
for having positive alignment and you
get D buffs if someone in your party
doesn't like everybody else in your
party so tower in time is 25 bucks which
for how much game is in here I think is
totally worth it if you're already a fan
of these kinds of isometric RPGs there's
a really good chance you'll be a fan of
this one and I would recommend it
alright I'm sick of talking about all
these complicated games let's go simple
okay I also played a game this week
called oh dear okay so if you like
old-school Sega games especially their
arcade racing titles like outrun and
super hang on and this is for you
oh dear is a game about drifting your
station wagon on your way to Grandma's
house and either killing or avoiding as
many deer as possible wait either that's
right
even so the beta version just came out
in the humble store which I'm basically
taking as an early access version and it
plays very much like a tuned up version
of outrun so the arcade style driving is
really fast it's really smooth the crazy
drifting in oh dear is what it's all
about so it's really easy to execute and
it feels really great to hold because of
the speed of the oncoming obstacles
there are a lot of long curvy roads and
long lines of deer to hit so you can
either go for a high score we aim to hit
as many do as possible or aim for a run
we get as few deer as possible so the
vibe of the music changes depending on
how many deer you kill or a boy and
apparently they're working on getting
the landscape is different as well the
music which is by this guy called motor
hero Kawashima who was one of the
composers of Streets of Rage 2 and 3 his
stuff which he Co composed is more in
line with I feel like trance and electro
music it really suits this sort of
bizarre game really well like I said
it's early access beta and it cost six
dollars and 66 cents on the Hummel stone
and it's a really great little pickup
and play arcade game that feels really
good to play it looks fantastic
and hopefully gets better as they went
from the full version oh and also
apparently uses uki who's the creator of
outrun Virtua Fighter and Shenmue played
this and said quote not too bad which is
a rousing endorsement you haven't heard
[Music]
all right well I'm glad that you guys
just spent a really long time watching
Diaz blow up bloody balloons cuz that's
a really good entree for the second game
I played this week which is also on the
simplest side it's called Friday the
13th killer puzzle so a little bit of a
Content warning here if you're a bit
squeamish this is a really fun slide
puzzle game that happens to have a very
gory premise related to Jason Voorhees
of course so this is the kind of puzzle
where you can only move in four
directions and wherever you move you
will always move to the end of the
possible space so your job is to kill
all the campers in every level by
navigating the levels while the severed
head of your mum cheers you on and helps
you out if need be
your victims basically need to be used
as puzzle pieces to get where you need
to go so early in the game it's just
about killing them while going between
those four lateral lines of movement and
that's fairly straightforward but when
you get up to episodes 3 & 4 each
episode contains about 13 levels it
starts to get really challenging and
there's only one right way to go about
each level so you can either restart the
level if you've completely messed it up
or if you just messed up the last move
you can just rewind it which is really
handy so you can play the game in PG or
argon mode PG has no screaming or blood
coming out of people personally I really
enjoy this game I like puzzles like this
a lot at the very end when you kill the
last camper there's a little slider at
the bottom that goes back and forth and
if you stop it over the red area you get
an execution some of these executions
are really funny depending on the
weapons that you have equipped at the
time he'll do different executions the
weapons aren't like different levels of
weapons it's really just for aesthetics
this is a free to play game up to
episode 8 and then episode 9 to 12 you
can buy for 3 bucks that might not sound
like much but I'd say it takes about
half an hour to do an episode each so
you do have a lot of game in there for
free you also buy weapons and rare
weapons if you really want to but
there's no reason to you earn them every
time you level one of the most excellent
things about this game is that there is
a button in the menu that when clicked
literally just makes that heart
mamma sound and it's great if this looks
like your thing the developer really
knows what they're doing this is
actually incredibly similar to a game
they made in 2016 called slay away camp
it's kind of just a fun time waster that
actually does get pretty challenging
once you get about 20-30 levels in so if
you like this kind of puzzle game and
you don't mind the gore it's a good way
to go all right so that does it for this
episode of steam Punk's if you played
any good games in the past week and we
didn't talk about them you should let us
know at our Twitter's I'm at Edmund Tran
no Matt just McDonnell until then we'll
see you next week for another episode of
steampunk
[Music]
[Music]